what up gamers today me and the boys are
playing microsoft flight simulator
i gotta play i'm flying gentlemen can
you confirm you're all at the airport
yes i got here three hours early like my
dad said here's the challenge there are
seven
super epic wonders of the world yeah
where
and whichever one of us visits all seven
of the world wonders first
wins 10 pcs oh my god 10 computers
i need a home setup xbox game pass was
nice enough to send me a super advanced
pilot setup
boys are you ready to race to all the
world wonders yes
on your marks get set go ah
engaging throttle hey boys all right
let's go to all the world wonders why is
your plane faster
watch your plane slower why is my plane
slowest
oh oh i'm in the air i'm in the air i'm
terrified
this is complicated how do i take off
the flat flaps up go faster left bumper
anybody all right i'm i'm falling
wait has chandler not taken off yet i i
flipped over like a
turtle on its back hey chris why are you
so far back i don't know i had to figure
out my flaps watch this
oh 360. 360. oh pull up pull bubba that
was a mistake that was a mistake how did
you not go down on that
i'm here when you get to the world
wonder you have to do a circle around it
and go back to the airport they're
telling me to leave the airspace i don't
think i'm supposed to be flying here
oh clean turn oh oh i'm getting close to
the river
all right hey taj mahal bye taj mahal
you guys already made it wait so
chandler have you made it to the taj
mahal yet uh
no why not i crashed the first time and
i like was on my back
and i couldn't get up so i had to
restart carl i'm gaining on you
all right we're gonna approach the
landing all right put my flaps up come
on baby
all right and a very smooth landing oh
my plane's upside down who put my plane
upside down
up pull up pull up i landed and it's
about to stop my plane's still stopping
i didn't land
on the landing pad but i landed now
chris yes
we're currently in india you're probably
wondering how do we go to the next world
wonder well how do we do that because
flight simulator has you fly
in real time so for us to fly from where
we are to the eiffel tower would
literally take like a day a day
that's how realistic this simulator is i
put seven file saves on all your
computers you just completed the first
one load up the second one to spawn in
france
alright just like real life you can load
a different safe i'm almost back we're
loading in france
i've always wanted to go to perry and it
just went completely nighttime
why is it night time come on baby break
break let's go
all right i successfully landed back at
the first airstrip okay i'm starting
disengage
parking brake engage throttle the wind's
like pushing me on the runway
yeah dude the wind is taking me man is
this proper flying condition should we
should we wait yeah you sit there and
wait oh my gosh
it's storming here boys my flaps are
disengaged now time to head to the
eiffel tower i feel like i could fly a
plane now irl right
this is easy as long as planes have xbox
controllers i assume they do
god yo paris is handsome look at this
map it is a skill replica
of the actual world can't wait to see it
this is insane imagine you live in that
building down there to the right
oh eiffel tower
okay i'm looping around the tower let's
take off how are you guys so far ahead
i was going so fast they told me
excessive air speed why don't i get
excessive air speed tolls
oh my god i almost just crashed i got
excessive air speed
speeding yeah good job you're breaking
the load
jimmy the wind is crazy bro i already
landed no way you're already landing
you're the lightning mcqueen of
airplanes
stopping and stopping and stopping stop
moving yo france can you tell them
clouds to calm down let's see if it's
cloudy in the pyramids bonjour and
goodbye
i can't turn how do you turn around
i need it all right i can't see the
airport but i'm coming in hot all right
here we go
landing parking brakes not fully engaged
yet
this looks beautiful oh my god it's
disgusting out in the pyramids why we're
just gonna
make this uh an airstrip oh wait there's
planes there's blades
imagine seeing an airplane like this
this low to the ground look at me
i'm bumping in this plane yo look at how
fast i'm climbing in speed
oh i see the pyramid this one's like 14
miles away
yo look at that look at the pyramids of
giza and while i'm on my way to this
pyramid i want to tell you about the
xbox game pass for pcs you can play over
100 games on your pc
look at all these games these are just a
few of them look at them all it was
recently announced that ea play is
coming to the xbox game pass for pc hey
let's go
let's go and you can join the xbox game
pass for pc for only one dollar click
the link in the description to learn
more and join now
all right here we go coming in for the
landing so am i so am i i'm landing
right now
oh i bounce yeah bro the bounce scares
me off all right i'm just landing in the
desert let's think about egypt a lot of
dirt to land in
eh oh there was a hill there i just did
a jump
all right we're gonna come doing stops
at some point oh hey chandler chandler
just flew black
hey oh why is it just turning it's just
turning yeah this one's reckless chris
we're doing an emergency landing oh my
gosh i barely dodged the house
i can't even fly it we're just gonna
land here oh trees we're just gonna land
here trees bro i straight up
crashed at the shinsu or whatever it's
called crash
landed and then got back in the air i'm
getting my brother a computer hey
i'm passing by chitsenitsu
oh my god this is beautiful jimmy look
at this with the sun glare in my
windshield
coming in for the landing all right and
i did it
let's get this land baby hey jimmy jimmy
now let's load the next one all right
we're going to brazil
we're going to brazil wait i'm passing
gabriel paladin he's not looking for
christ the redeemer like i am though hey
chandler what world wonder are you on
i'm on chicken pizza dude i'm getting
just mere feet away from these trees at
this mountain wait chris you're on the
fifth world wonder yeah carl well you're
on the fifth world wonder too carl
yeah yeah well brazil's beautiful what
the heck chrysler redeemer
oh my gosh oh my gosh stop flipping i'm
upside down stop stop stop stop pull up
pull okay okay okay stop stop stop and
dive
oh all right we're coming in hot we're
coming in hot touch the ground yeah this
plane
was a butt to get off the ground but now
that we got
it we're headed to christ the redeemer
chris look how close i was to hitting
those streets
press y or whatever your break is ah
stop something engage the brain
i'm gonna i'm gonna say we'll count it
but it was kind of sloppy it was sloppy
hey look at that there's christ the
redeemer
hey carl where are you at i died this is
my first time crashing and i'm gonna
lose now
that didn't work my plane just folded
like a piece of paper
i might crash too cause i just the
altitude right when you get up on it is
hard yeah dude that's what i'm
struggling with and then i just nose
dive okay
wait so we're all kind of in the same
area now right except for chandler all
right
i'm about to be there guys don't worry
all right landed successfully hey chris
eat my dust noob there's literally
nothing i could freaking do
hey i'm on the same one as you know
faster faster
jimmy did you go around christ the
redeemer i'm not there yet i'm flying
towards it has anybody been able to get
the altitude to go around it yet i
almost got the altitude yeah everybody's
in brazil now yeah yeah yeah
me and carl are neck and neck oh yeah
then we're all basically tied right now
anyone here could take home the 10 pcs
let's go
if i win 10 random people who leave a
comment on this video are getting a pc
chris have you made it yet no i'm right
behind you yeah what the heck why is my
plane stalling no way
my plane died oh yeah i got it i got it
i went around i did it
oh my plane's stalling yo that was
impossible that actually gave me like
butterflies because i got nervous i got
nervous and still crashed into the
mountain
okay i crashed like 15 times jimmy oh
what's up hey wire hornet 87.
hey look i see him too jimmy uh-huh
uh-huh watch this
carl if you crash it you got to restart
ah jimmy no
jimmy you do realize you'll go straight
through me nope
oh you disappeared all right i have
flown around the mountain and i'm headed
back oh god the coliseum's up next the
next plane
may just be the slowest plane yet hey
you boy with the smooth landing
look at those cars yo that looks like a
real life video oh
coliseum i got it i got it i'm proud of
you jimmy look at that there's jesus
it is crazy that in this simulator have
a skill replica of the world you can
literally fly
anywhere you see right now on the map
this is actually kind of nuts dude wait
who's mr beastgaming30 hey
your boy yo you just have barely enough
runway to make this take off don't you
yeah dude that's what i'm saying this
one sucks at takeoff i overshot the
runway i gotta turn around
or not or no
that works coliseum more like coliseum
right there
there we go grand canyon here we go
let's take it home
to america baby why is this one 26 miles
away dude this last one has to be 26
miles away wait carl you're already on
the last world wonder
yeah we took it back home to america
approaching the grand
canyon look guys i see the canyon i'm
going over it oh the air speed is going
too high
the boy starts hanging out with dream
and suddenly he's got to speed run
everything
oh carl you already landed you're so
you're about to complete the last
challenge
yes is that the colosseum i thought that
was the coliseum guys hurry carl's about
to win
chris i can't do anything about it drive
faster oh i'm going too fast
come on
officially at the airport chris yes
you're flying
mm-hmm and i'm flying uh-huh so how's
carl here i don't know i guess he's
flying
finished does that mean you what
all right i'm coming down with it
you did just win 10 pcs i'm gonna give
away one
to whoever comments carl is handsome so
one person that comments carl is
handsome on this video you'll give him a
computer yes
it's so nice of you she's just such a
giving all right i'm cutting it off